hello everybody my name is Mark Levine
and welcome to don't spill your coffee
now as far as silly little games go this
is probably the silliest little game
that I could possibly find but just
imagine the scenario you're walking to
work cuz that's what you do you walk to
work with your coffee in hand
it's not even in like a mug or a thermos
you stupidly put it in a cup from your
home but you you it's too early in the
morning you haven't had your coffee yet
and you gotta get to work because you're
running late then all of a sudden
gravity betrays you everything's gone
wrong the for the fool anyway there's
like 15 levels to this game and then
some customization options and I don't
know I don't know I I played around with
it and there's various different hair
options and I kind of liked the pigtails
not gonna lie not gonna lie thicken the
pigtails also a beard cuz pigtails and
beard is best combo yeah it looks good
the skin color oh that's weird
it's like Squidward if he grew pigtails
and a beard can I have a nose
customization can I extend this nose out
please okay let's assume this guy has no
grundle and just decided to forget his
pants it's a very early morning I mean
when the floor is rebelling against you
and gravity decided to [ __ ] with your
mind and then Cthulhu pops through the
door it's gonna be a rough day for you
so anyway let's get to it I actually
have never played this game before in my
life and this guy looks like oh my god
why is he thrust into the ground dude
stop oh wow yeah yeah this good for
lumbar support right oh I can walk with
my human legs oh I can try to not spill
by human coffee
let me just thrust upwards holy [ __ ] if
I if I was taking this more seriously
I'd be frustrated at the controls let us
take this one step at a time
with my floor gun feet I mean human feet
okay oh okay just gotta get through this
turnstile apparently let's go through
the
human control device oh [ __ ]
I don't know what's happening what why
did this not work
hey okay yeah let me just spill that on
my crotch my non-existent crotch yep
do I get also how do I white I don't
know do I use the door device ah very
smart okay hang on I got this
what yep there we go yep nope I got it
don't worry about it I can get back up
from this I can recover how hard it is
to actually human Oh key card oh the key
cards in my butt I gotta put my butt up
to this thing I get it now okay so I
just got a back dad ass up into the key
card dispensary throws on me that wasn't
my fault it freakin froze I gotta do the
rage worm the games against life
visiting me hold on I say I'm not loot
savings what a great deal what a great
buy again I know what I'm doing now it
just got a bow you know every once in a
while
pay my respects to the dead you know
spill out some coffee for those that we
have lost in this endeavor back up back
up back up there we go forward
whoa boy burn whoa is awfully hard well
there's harder than you think guys whoa
whoa that's not right
give me that I'm so close it's so
tantalizingly close all right all right
all right
the victory caffeine boost okay
you made it to your meeting you had
great ideas press a to go to the next
one I'll try one more
is gonna go oh I think this is fo Shan
Oh play does that mean this doesn't
exactly make it very difficult just put
in a different spot mmm back that ass up
[ __ ] I'm in it to win it
yeah normal human normal human through
the normal human turnstile coffee yes
[ __ ] like oh god how am I supposed to be
able to do that I don't have whoops [ __ ]
oh ok there's other controls get it get
it man well I was always hoping that I'd
have this intimate control over my
buttocks I'm glad that this day has
finally come to me ok yep
lower it oh no oh ok let's try to get
through it like this yeah that's normal
mmm my normal human walking pose yes yes
have a good day lovely fellow humans
let me just journey my massive booty
through the turnstile ok vertically
challenged I don't know if that means is
this is this saying that I can raise my
butt into the air get it up oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude
[ __ ] dude well I'm just gonna crab it
over here in the corner no one mind me
while I gently do my hip extension
exercises yeah raise it raise it gotta
lean back raise it raise it raise it
lean back lean this way raise it raise
it oh [ __ ] we're getting the terminal
ass extension that's it gotta back that
ass up back it up
okay try to make it like this now
whoa human [ __ ] you we're terminal
raising you loop got it hey whoa jeez up
there drop it down drop that ass that
ass is out of control you drop that down
now you drop that down now drop what
yeah well good thing you upper against
the wall drop it down drop it down drop
it down drop it down drop it down a
little more now that's in control that's
what I call in control whoa
not really whoa very drunk this I spiked
my coffee with a lot of odd cut before
the note oh oh [ __ ] god damn it good
thing I can get my ass up there we go I
trip over my own feet it's not my fault
I just gotta raise it up and then
immediately raise it down cuz that's how
you say raising down won't we okay let's
make it through well not what [ __ ] do it
help that just go just go that's all the
time I got for don't spill your coffee
this game is actually pretty much
delightful I love this I love stupid
ideas like this if you guys got more
cool games that I can play like this let
me know in the comments below so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
okay oh yeah marquee lights
now bronchi wants a whiff of my booty